okay cinemasins
ET now why not jaws while you're at it
oh wait it's not like this puddle will
be very hard to avoid especially once
the first person goes through dude
couldn't have looked back and said Jim
Steve watch out for the puddle nothing
like some bright headlights and keys
jangling to make the thing you're
hunting for unaware you're approaching
et's raises a dick to ET also did these
aliens discover interstellar travel but
not radio communications and aren't they
telepathic or empathic anyway I've gotta
say it makes for a great wordless
opening to your movie but where are the
communication tools of this advanced
alien race
don't worry T will be back later when
the danger is just as bad as it is now
only you'll have had a satisfying to our
adventure by that so it'll be cool to
come back at that time also why are they
leaving him the spaceship can take off
that fast then why not wait a few more
seconds I mean Daniel like most great
D&D sessions this one requires plenty of
soda snacks
air freshener and raid is this asshole
requesting a radio station to play the
Oakridge boys Elvira as a kid who grew
up in Tennessee when that song was
popular I'm pretty sure such a request
is a hate crime plenty of sausage they
tellin Elliot what they want a pizza is
it an order aren't they waiting for the
pizza isn't that why the one dude said
these kids even order pizzas like
assholes like one pizza and you're
pulling an all-night D&D game you
deserve all the radio stations playing
Elvira on repeat from this point forward
the dungeon master says so the 80s well
it was perfectly okay to give your
friends mom's ass a wet willy if you're
an 80 that is hiding why would you throw
the ball back furthermore why would you
hide in the shed with all its lights on
coyotes come back again mom no kidding
Peter Coyote is probably lurking around
the corner as we speak in fact he's
lurking while you're watching this video
he's right behind you if it was such a
big deal that these kids ordered a pizza
how did they think they were gonna get
away with it and why are they leaving
that pizza outside sure some cheese got
stuck to the box but it's still pizza
I didn't eat dee run before Elliot found
him he ran last time flashlights were
near him why would this be any different
this works also how does Elliot know
where to start putting the candy out why
didn't he just go through the gate
the et clearly went through the night
before and up into the force that way
not sure of et is around here but some
of those coyotes Michael mentioned in
the previous scene might want to come
out of the dark for some snacks
et let's Eliot know he wants M&Ms
instead of this bullshit less than a
minute ago et made it pretty clear by
approaching Elliot and he was willing to
hang not sure why he needs this
breadcrumb trail to get him to follow as
if he T knows he's going to be shot with
a camera angle that will make him more
mysterious he reaches for the Reese's
Pieces from the stairs when just seconds
ago he had no problem standing in front
of Elliot probably because the lighting
obscured his face just enough I mean
he's a veteran of stage and film so he
knows how to play to the audience nobody
in the house hears this Elliot et's
smart enough to know what Elliot is
trying to tell it just don't give up we
drink it it's a it's a dream and here's
a bunch of ants all over my room from
all this food and drink I leave lying
around le it's definitely in the Greedo
shot first camp how did he get all those
stuffed animals to form a wall around it
unless there was a production assistant
there to help it this guy plays football
and wears a Space Invaders t-shirt not
to mention he plays D&D man the girls in
this school must be really confused on
whether to date this guy also if et was
in that closet all night it's got a
smell right those stuffed animals are
probably covered with urine and feces
look I understand the reveal of Peter
Coyote is going to blow everyone's mind
and his character is listed as keys in
this movie but what's up with the
fucking keys already why can't we show
his face is he really all that
mysterious the thing et's biological and
digestive system is just like a human
span he doesn't have any food allergies
hooli inspires an awful Atari 2600 game
that I played for a ridiculous amount of
hours back in the day nerd rap battle
seems odd that Elliot gets to ride his
bike to school but Michael has to take
the bus and wasn't Mary driving Michael
and Gertie to school the day before I
would et have the wherewithal to hide
amongst the stuffed animals like that
and furthermore why would he be worried
about Mary finding him anyways he has no
reason I think she's hostile or means
him any harm v8 from everything we've
seen before this Elliot has gotten the
food for et so how does et even know
where the food is or how to open a
refrigerator door so ET is getting drunk
and by extension
it gets drunk because of the bond
they've made so didn't eat these buddies
at the beginning of this movie no he was
still alive and he was running towards
the ship thankfully a kind man was
selling these right outside the school
whose white van he said any of you were
more than welcome to stop by for free
candy on your way out today look I know
et and Elliott are connected by alien
magic but he'd also have to be
controlling Erica Eleni acts movements
to make this work look just because I
love it doesn't mean I won't send it and
what the fuck is this asshole doing this
might be the first ever block turned
into a assist apparently all the kids
got on board with Elliott's plan to free
the frogs even though moments ago most
of the frogs were being pushed into a
glass case and the teacher must have
gone to bang the janitor or something
because he's nowhere in sight Jesus how
many frogs did this teacher get for the
class if the kids just threw 30 frogs
out the window and there's another 10
here I'm guessing the school district
has way too much money for frog
purchases let's see a blender pencil
sharpener a Speak & Spell
radio some aluminum foil and a popcorn
maker this is an orgy of evidence the et
has no clue what he's doing she's
leaving dirty by herself at 5:00 mother
of the year wait a minute are you saying
Gerdes room connects to Elliot's through
this closet so when we see the closet
from this angle we see everybody's
standing in front of a wall and the exit
to Eliot's room is on the right on the
left there's a bunch of clothes hanging
and in front of them et is standing in
front of a wall so how is this closet
possible that was Mary the only one that
never walks in on these shenanigans no
kid said about science unless they are
harboring an alien so does this kind of
closet have convenient adjustable blinds
I don't remember being able to do this
with closet doors before but then again
et is about to build a space radio using
a pencil sharpener
so maybe I shouldn't be surprised you
gotta love those 1980s visual effects I
know their mom is just assuming that's
Gertie but Jesus does she not notice her
daughter has shrunk by a full foot the
least he could do is Crane his neck to
get the height right also moments ago we
saw the g-men listening to the
conversations in the house meaning that
the house is but how could they not know
et is out with the kids right now method
trick-or-treating I love how this movie
connects to Star Wars and it's almost
sin removal worthy but I'm a dick so in
this universe Star Wars movies and toys
exist elliot showed
et his Star Wars action figures earlier
meaning this movie has effectively made
Star Wars a documentary also Star Wars
is famously a long time ago in a galaxy
far far away so how the fuck does et
know Yoda I know in this
we're sprinkles we CET so not that it
really matters but if I gave this movie
the benefit of the doubt I suppose it's
possible
et read the Star Wars simulator gives an
arbitrary time to be back like one hour
after sunset its merry afraid of
vampires why wouldn't you just say be
back at eight o'clock like a normal
parent keys and his goons have been all
over this forest every night but
conveniently aren't when Elliott and et
are right out in the open hmm remove us
in for the famous moon shot or Addison
for the Bruce Almighty moon it's off to
go with my gut and do the right thing
Elliott pedals his bike fruitlessly as a
magic alien makes it fly yeah yeah we'd
all pedal the bike even though there's
almost no friction but I'm sending it
anyway
I guess these assholes knew that Mary
would be driving out of here at any
moment so that they could do their men
in black in the now-empty house this
Rube Goldberg space phone is actually
working not only did the g-men know that
Mary would leave the house but that it
would take just long enough to do all
this in the house Elliott managed to get
into the house without the usual noises
of a door opening and closing also
despite Elliott looking near death he
biked all the way back here
why is Gertie the designated bath drawer
make that lazy ass Michael do it he's
older but I guess she knows that Elliott
needs michael to go find ET later I mean
wait no one will remain seated during
the exciting car follows bike at a safe
distance and speed scene I guess keys
and his crew have been seeking out all
the shortcuts preparing for a future
chase scene also as no one reported the
mysterious car that been creeping
through the neighborhood every night for
the past week why are the tires
squealing dudes going maybe five
unassuming there's a rational
explanation for how Michael piles a near
dead et in the basket of his bicycle he
and Elliot needed each other's help
putting him in the basket earlier but
sure this kid can lift him off the
ground carry him up the hill and put him
neatly in the basket all by himself
check these assholes long enough nothing
to see here folks just trying to get
some exercise in thus begins a full 15
minutes of et dying
seriously these look like astronaut
suits and not hazmat suits right step in
the costume designers day off and
Spielberg just said close enough why
don't have to push the quarantine tube
down the road I don't they have their
equipment right in front of the house
sure it makes for a dramatic shot but it
also adds unneeded strain to workers who
were probably already stressed out from
learning Donald Trump will be President
in 35 years meanwhile Elliot's neighbors
are conspicuously quiet during the
government raid ah Peter Coyote
he doesn't have four nucleotides like we
do he has six yeah but how many
midi-chlorians did you count those what
about his thetan levels
he's converting back to normal sinus
rhythm separating the yada-yada the out
of that plot point this is a beautiful
shot and a sad scene but Spielberg he
knew exactly what he was doing the power
of love brings et all the way back from
the dead as if he didn't feel it until
Elliot said it Buffon gotta say the
five-year-old in me is removing a sin
for this copy
[Music]
how does ET know what that means man if
you knew what that meant why don't you
say something more than et phone home
the fact that Elliot is in any way
allowed to walk through this tube and
approach the supposedly dead alien
coffin
so did Michael managed to get the keys
to this van somehow or did the g-men
leave the keys in the ignition Mike
screams his instructions to his friends
loud enough so everyone knows exactly
where they're going
if et2 were ever made Michael would be
in jail the whole time serving his
consecutive life sentences for the two
doctors he brutally murdered jeez all
these government agencies and they can't
stop this car from backing out of the
driveway what is that gonna do they're
going to chase after the bike that has
the et shaped lump in the basket right I
mean what did that do none of the cars
can follow any of those bikes so what
did seperating get them the Sun is
sinking at an alarming rate guys I think
what this and the moon we should
probably start recycling more she
doesn't come on dude do you know how
much bolt we went through to come back
get your ass on this ship do this none
of the other g-men managed to make it to
this clearing despite knowing where the
alien UFO landed the first time maybe on
its next visit et will have learned the
art of giving people a warning before
you stick that penis shaped glowing
finger in their face
[Music]
ah shucks I can't hate anything about
this movie I mean come on
John Williams score he gets to go home
we don't learn a valuable lesson about
alien pets I got to remove ass in a
restless encounter it's got a break and
magically get revived again Uranus and
the shark eats a fish case goes in the
water you gonna order charts in order
our shower
a lot of people stay that's no moon it's
a space station I am I know now why you
cry
but it's something I can never do
[Music]
goodbye
I think I miss you most of all